Becca is with us in Fort Wayne Indiana
to start off this hour hi Becca
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you so much sure what do you think
before I it sounds cheesy but I am so
grateful for God's faithfulness and that
what we can't handle he totally can
I don't think that's true at all that's
awesome very cool so how can I help
today well in a nutshell my 18 year old
brother is living with my husband and I
and he is a recovering drug addicts and
he's doing really great but we're trying
to help him figure out how to manage
money as he's starting to get a job but
not give him you know we don't want him
to relapse and get in control of that
money and he's never had a good money
example so just how to help him we're
giving FPU for Christmas than that you
know it's a little different with
addicts as I've heard you talk about
well that's excellent excellent advice
an excellent thing for him to do you
know recovery always involves multiple
parts of your life it involves not only
just staying sober the sobriety part of
it but real sobriety involves
relationships and career choices and
money choices and taking care of your
physical body and you know what it
amounts to is you just start taking care
of life and you've completely ignored it
before because you were because of the
addiction and so it's it's part of his
thing to learn to handle money now and
it's not like that's going to cause a
relapse it's quite the opposite the more
he takes control of these different
areas of his life the more his sobriety
is going to be strengthened does that
make sense so yeah I think it's
wonderful he's getting a job and then
what I would do is just be all up in his
business you have a right to your
furnishing in a place to live you're
participating and cheering him on in his
in his sobriety and so I'm holding him
accountable on any area of his
if I'm you that needs to help him move
forward you know I mean he needs to get
the job he needs to show up and work
hard at the job he needs to smile and be
grateful for the job that's the career
side of the equation money side of the
equation is we're gonna go over your
budget with you kiddo and we're gonna
we're gonna love you we don't need any
of your money and we're not trying to be
control freaks but we are gonna look at
it with you and part of you getting free
rent here is you winning and winning
involves you touching that area of your
life and we want to hold you accountable
to that and any one needs accountability
and 18 year old especially needs
accountability an 18 year old in
recovery really needs accountability
right and so that's not controlling it's
not micromanaging it's just loving him
well to be kindly gently but very firmly
in these different areas of his life so
you know if I'm in your shoes him living
there's gonna have some for free which
is what I what I would suggest but it's
gonna have the way he pays rent is he's
he's gonna allow us to walk with him and
cheer him on and hold him accountable in
these different parts of his life that
he's now got to put back together so
yeah that's great and then just work you
know whatever he's got I'm sure he's got
some debt probably to clean up from this
time and you work through that so hey
thanks for the call
we appreciate you joining us